the current Northern Ireland secretary
and the former Chief whip Chris Heaton
Harris who joins us now thank you very
much for being with us so you're backing
Boris Johnson just explain to us why
um well because he's a vote winner he's
got a mandate from the last general
election
um and I know from the reaction that my
another my friend friends who are MPS
who went out canvassing yesterday got on
the doorstep that he is still a vote
winner today he's the one person labor
fears
you know I'm really happy to have you on
the program because you know I know that
you are you know close to Boris Johnson
you served as his chief whip you
delivered him the difficult news last
time when you told him that you believed
the game was up so I feel like you know
if anyone's going to know where his head
is at maybe you can help us on that
um is he really going to run
uh yeah I think so I mean I'm calling
for I really am calling for Instagram
I'm trying to work out the um uh uh you
know the numbers and I think the numbers
are actually Sophie we do have the
numbers just so you know um uh
everybody's speculating but the Ricky
Camp knows me up the numbers the penny
Camp knows we have the numbers so
um that's not um uh an issue um and this
is a time when we need a big player like
Boris in our politics so
um I think he will
um you know you say that you have the
numbers uh over 100 MPS that's what
we've been briefed as well but obviously
the the declared backers are much much
lower than that so you know we just have
to take your word for it is it a bit
like saying you know I have got a
girlfriend but you wouldn't know her she
goes to a different School
um no I mean I so the one thing I was
relatively good at as Chief whip was
numbers and
um we definitely have uh enough uh
numbers to get um well we've already
booked the appointment with Bob Blackman
the uh Secretary of the 1922 tomorrow so
yeah we've got the numbers why are they
so shy at being named then
um I'm not sure they're particularly shy
I mean there's some people who are uh in
government positions uh who um uh and
there are some people who might be whips
or uh on the 22 executive or uh you know
in positions where they don't want to
come forward but they don't have to I
mean only two people actually have to be
named on the nomination paper and it uh
and in the votes it's a secret palette
so
um I guess you could say a secret ballot
is part of democracy and um nominations
similarly
the reason I'm asking about the numbers
is because obviously he hasn't declared
yet we haven't got a hundred uh public
uh backers I'm just trying to work out
the seriousness of this leadership
campaign you know if you've kind of
flown back dramatically from the
Caribbean he's called up James dodridge
his allies say I'm up for it dudders in
you know sort of typical exuberant form
but you know I can't work out exactly
whose campaign team is whether he's
going to declare who the 100 backers are
we all kind of falling into you know the
great Boris Johnson soap opera again I
mean are you have you spoken to him yeah
I've spoken to him and
um I I yeah well I think at this point
in time he's he's um Keen to see what
the Parliamentary party thinks uh you
know he he can be a he is actually
um a great unifier he is a great
campaigner and he is someone who um has
a solid sense of what the country wants
um to hear and what the country needs to
happen so um yeah I mean yes he flew
back yesterday oh just be quite Frank
none of us expected this to happen at
all
um you know it was one of those weird I
I've never had quite I've had plenty of
weird times in my recent political
career but it was one of those very
weird moments
um
uh this week where uh I I did not expect
this trust to uh to resign on Thursday
um so lots has happened in a very short
period of time and the fact that we've
got the numbers after such a short
period of time with no campaign with
very little organization and
realistically uh just a few people
calling around demonstrates to me the
support for Boris Johnson that's in the
Parliamentary party also demonstrates to
me uh the the amount of email and and
social media traffic that we're all
getting now demonstrates to me that he's
really popular in the country too
uh you he had talks with Rishi sunak
last night everyone's been very
tight-lipped about what's happened we
don't know what happened you say that
you've spoken to him do you have any
steer on what did actually go on last
night
um I I know they had talks but you'll
have to give me I was doing something a
bit more social with her nephew's 21st
birthday
um last night so I
um uh I felt like I got up a bit early
just to be on on here so if you because
I I had a very good fun time with my
nephew last night okay well we
appreciate the early alarm uh in that uh
situation and do you think if Rishi
sooner offered him a job in his cabinet
that Boris Johnson would accept it or is
he only interested in the top job no I
mean to answer your question seriously
the last question seriously I mean I I
was really pleased that um that they had
talked so I honestly don't know what
transpired from those talks
um and I will be speaking uh to Boris uh
quite shortly and I'd like to these
things
um I I think it's really important that
the the party unifies and come and comes
together and I really do think it's
important that the country gets the
message that we are serious about
governing and we are serious about
sorting out the economic situation we
find ourselves in that's trying to
change so dramatically and such a short
period of time that we're serious about
dealing with the international factors
that contribute to that that we have a
leader that's going to be unbelievably
strong when it comes to supporting
Ukraine and facing down uh Putin that we
are an understanding of the economic
situation we find ourselves in and so
yeah I I want those talks between
um Rishi and Boris to continue because I
think and indeed to involve Penny
because these are all big players in our
future and if they came together I think
it would be a dramatic
um turn for the better for us all
you're talking about birthstone for
being an election winner you talk about
his action on Ukraine you could talk
about his understanding of the economic
situation and I really want to ask the
question that I actually think is really
important because you know we get sucked
into all this drama what actually is the
economic strategy that Boris Johnson is
running on because I don't know what is
it well I mean I mean to be frank we've
only been working at a campaign for 24
hours
um I I as a member of the government I I
don't think the economic strategy
couldn't change much because we need to
make sure that our economy is completely
stable so um and currently Jeremy Hunt
is the chance of exchecker and then I'll
go the chief Secretary of the Treasury
are working on an economic plan uh for
the medium term and I'm quite sure that
all the candidates will want to commit
to something like that because that's
what you know we want to make sure that
we have a stable economy to build
forward on so will brush Johnson commit
to the Jeremy Hunt plan because it feels
quite important you know if you're going
to back him say you should be the next
prime minister to know
yeah he was Boris absolutely wants a
stable financial and economic background
for the country to move forward on and
to me
um and obviously you know we don't know
what um as a campaign team that's only
been formed 24 hours and been making uh
uh telephone calls you know we've not
had privy information as to what that
might look like and or should we have
but
um I'm a as a member of the government I
think Jeremy Hunt's plan is probably the
best one in town
you should know though shouldn't you if
you're like going around calling people
asking them to put their faith in Boris
you should know exactly what is an
economic plan is shouldn't you I mean
the bank of England have to step in to
stop a run on Pension funds recently
yeah and then but the economic plan that
will have will be based on stability for
the economy um but as I say the only
plan that's being worked on currently
with all the detail that you need to
have an economic plan is the one that
Jeremy Hunt's working on now okay um I
want to talk a little bit more about
what a Boris uh Premiership could mean
we had Steve Baker on the program uh at
the beginning of the show he's backing
Rishi sunak he said that it would be a
disaster if Bosch Johnson would be prime
minister because of the Privileges
committee he said he couldn't rule out
voting against the Prime Minister if he
felt that he had misled Parliament he
said that other conservative MPS would
be in the same situation you know at a
time when the country is in the
situation that it is after all that the
conservative party have put it through
over the last couple of months is it
really responsible to put in power
someone who could end up being found
guilty of misleading Parliament and
suspended from Parliament as a result
yeah I mean let's put all this into some
context so um firstly uh Boris was happy
for the Privileges committee
investigation to be set up you know a
conservative party member MPS did not
have to vote on that
um secondly he's very you know he's he's
been working over the summer he's you
know he's absolutely sure
um that he's going to be exonerated
thirdly he's you know we are very happy
for the Privileges committee to continue
its work we he wants the Privileges
committed to continue its work because
he he believes he will be exonerated as
do I
um and then I don't know what this vote
is that people are talking about
immediately as we get back privileges
committee has not started its work uh
for uh properly yeah there's a long way
to go
um yeah evidence will be taken
um I'm sure there'll be one or two press
press uh columns written about it and
I'm sure Sophie you'll have some time on
your show dedicated to it um
but uh only if the Privileges committee
uh were to find him uh uh in some way in
error would there be any any worry about
a penalty at all and I don't believe
that would be the case so we were
talking I think about many many months
um down the line that it's just a
theoretical possibility
no we can't you know just underplay the
importance of of this they can we as
well you know Boris Johnson quit when
his own MPS lost confidence in him he
was the only serving prime minister to
have been found to have broken the law
you know people like William Hague for
example saying on Friday he risks
sending the party into a death spiral is
he really the answer to the problems the
conservative party now faces well
there's I mean there's polling today
that suggests very strongly that he is
um you know without any campaigning just
um uh uh flying back um from the
Dominican Republic
um there's polling that suggests that he
pulls us back within 26 seats if there
was a general election called
um tomorrow of Labor and that's without
him saying that polling so yeah
according to that public so but yeah
Boris Johnson is unbelievably popular
with the public he can connect with the
public like a few other politicians of
my generation and I doubt we'll see any
anyone like him again he has a mandate
with the British people he won the 2019
election with a massive 80-seat majority
unheard of uh since the times of
Margaret with Thatcher and Tony Blair
and this is you know this is a man who
actually does know how to govern who can
govern and uh given the chance would
happily govern again
you know things are very different back
in 2019 though as I'm sure you will
admit when Boris Johnson did win at that
election uh not just because he was up
against Jeremy corbyn as well you know
Boris Johnson actually had positive
approval ratings for a few months you
know by January this year there were
minus 52 that's lower than Theresa May
or David Cameron ever got that's that's
why your colleagues got rid of him
um well I mean if we were four or five
points behind in the polls um as well
um but I mean
when you when you get when you get to a
general election everybody's mind
concentrates on uh first of all special
the country and indeed who you know what
sort of
um uh prime minister uh they would like
now Boris Johnson the show has
demonstrated that he can
um touch like the Heineken of British
politics you know his popularity can
touch anywhere in the country whatsoever
he can get and absolutely anywhere get
votes from anywhere he is still that
popular
um now he can demonstrate um to the
Parliamentary party he's a man that
everybody wants to talk to he's a man
that lights up a room when he comes into
it so yeah he can he can pull this
around and he'll have he has already a
track record of delivery on brexit on
Covert
um on on dealing with the uh the first
ramifications that flowed from Putin's
illegal invasion of crane so there's a
whole host of things delivery and indeed
hope for the future that Boris gives us
would you like to see him offer the
chancellorship to Rishi sunak if he does
make it I I'd very much like the two of
them and as I say penny as well because
I think Penny's got a great is is a
great talent um and we have we have got
some amazing uh great amazing talents in
our in our party I'd like to see
everybody work together so we can um
move on from the position we're in now
I mean Jacob Reed Smoker's been pictured
with the slogan Boris or bust that
doesn't sound like someone who is
working together does it uh yeah but
that I've got to say uh our mini
campaign does not have an official
slogan or anything like that so that was
just something someone else had mocked
up Jacob used it um I I think that's a
bit unfortunate obviously but it's just
uh you can't stop people being
enthusiastic about Boris okay and now I
want to ask you a question with your
Northern Ireland hat on you're obviously
the Secretary of State for Northern
Ireland and you've said uh that you know
there will be an election triggered uh
if the uh assembly there doesn't manage
to get up and running uh you of course
are currently a Secretary of State for
an online and that could change in a
couple of days time uh whoever is in
that job what do you think we need to
see now
um well so the election would be uh
would be cool because actually it's a
legal requirement um it's it's primary
legislation that um if six months passes
without an executive uh reforming for
the normal nine assembly
um after the previous election then an
election has to be called so it's
actually a legal requirement to call it
a one minute past midnight on the 28th
of October
um and so whoever sits in the seats of
the Northern Ireland secretary at that
time and I truly hope it's me but who
knows
um uh you will be in that position so
the the Democratic unions party uh have
got an opportunity to come back in it's
really important actually uh that I I
think that they do because there's so
many domestic issues in Northern Ireland
that would be helped
um by their re-entry into the executive
and they've got some really talented
politicians themselves who can help sort
those uh those issues out
um so there is a choice that people can
make to stop there being election but
it's got to be made by elective
Representatives as well moment going
back in to that assembly so without that
um the secretary state from Northern
Ireland would have to call an election
this week
and just finally while I've got you
um why was Boris Johnson on holiday when
Parliament was sitting
um well it would have been slipped so uh
so yeah uh I think you'll find um
a number we've got a couple of former
Prime Ministers uh now sitting on the
back benches and because they are truly
big beasts in our parliamentary system
uh as a chief whip with one of them asks
you if they could have some time off to
do something you'd normally say yes what
does slip do mean you mean he would have
got permission to go off on a on a nice
holiday yes you get permission to go
away okay so again we very much
commissioned so campaigning you know
that sort of thing yeah
permission to go on holidays as usual
then
it's it's it's a thing
okay all right uh Christine Harris thank
you very much for being on the program
uh today